at the beginning I protest for two
nights of their so and I try to think of
something which I can do more frightened
to draw this picture and even I saw this
again that that feeling comes again this
are when we are on the first row people
pass umbrellas they hold it and it can
protect you I was facing the policeman
I've never imagined this would happen in
my life I never thought I have to be
opposite to the police
what else
les shops now business looking bad if we
finish the work in two days it is five
but it's a high comedy it can you have a
loved one that you are in a high polygon
Cornetto t so you see I think today
there will be 10 people helping us maybe
more
but if 10 people having us we can finish
it by tomorrow morning I think
and because of the smell the smell of
the umbrella because because of the rain
and we put it back to the storage room
for two days then after we get it out in
this really smelly
home it's wet that no magic baby
when we interact with the
local independent shops we know that
their main problem is the ranks
property here is very expensive so we
wanted to some Soho luxury house like in
the most expensive area in Hong Kong
here we are looking at different
criterias such as the constructions
materials or the functions such as can
it prevent the Sun or the rain which you
get every
now
when I was kid together
Brenda my whole world oh my best friend
leave Hong Kong they moved to many
country like American handles Australia
I was really unhappy and my mom said
because the Communists don't and on is
coming to take over Hong Kong and the
rich people have to leave even even me
myself to care about the political thing
it's just maybe this two years thing
government tried to launch national
education subject to the youngster and
the content is all about loving your
gray China and that there was the moment
I I realized we should take control from
for our future it's really hard to
control the pan
removers like our lives see you
another foul language and west
I will explain to you
he who created from back out of our
couch six eight nights and other foul
language I have the lithography
time the which is not after time to rate
it is oh yeah you check out nice out see
why Sir sagramor tech click seek and
save and take a coffee get my coin the
policeman jets track here track him to a
place a secret place and then they just
punches using Fowler's to to solve the
problems
yeah and we think it is a little bit
dangerous for us to set up in admiralty
tonight because there are dancing
felice amount so intense we are so angry
and feel so disappointed about the
action of the police and for us we can
do nothing without his problem
this place is really a public area
because usually when we want to set up
some artwork in public we have to ask
for the government many times and they
would have to meeting and discussed if
this work can put it here but this time
MOT here is is really for the citizen
it's now really a public place because
all those umbrella was established by
the police then I hope that this damaged
that umbrella can protect the citizen in
a different kind of way it just reminds
people that this controllers are broken
and there are some people around beside
you or just behind you to support you in
a different kind of format